Їм обіцяли комфортне життя
посеред зеленої зони неподалік Ірпеня
Але мешканцям цих котеджів довелося попрощатися із затишком нещодавно
коли до лісу прийшли лісоруби -
під охороною спортивних молодикІв
Виносили людей, били, закручували,
поліція була бездіяльна
Місцева громада розгорнула боротьбу проти ірпінських чиновників
за припинення вирубки дерев
Зараз справа знаходиться в суді
Є клопотання прокурора про накладення арешту на цю ділянку
щоб унеможливити якісь подальші дії
Ми намагаємося якомога швидше і ефективніше
ці ділянки повернути громаді
Сутички на будівельних майданчиках, напади на громадських активістів
непоодинокі явища в Ірпіні за останні кілька років
Ірпінь - точка місцевого Чикаго
Вже всі загальноукраїнські ЗМІ пишуть про те
що це поєднання криміналітету
із правлячими хабарниками
Все відбувається через шалені гроші
що обертаються навколо активної забудови Ірпеня
каже Лаврентій Кухалейшвілі, один з захисників місцевих зелених зон
За його даними протягом останніх трьох років
тут з’явилося майже 1 200 000
квадратних метрів житла
І всі ці будинки виросли на місці,
де досі стояли вікові ліси
Залишилося з 1450 гектарів десь 100 гектарів
Решта вже знищена і забудована
Десь гектарів 30 цієї території
ми просто фізично не даємо забудувати
Громадські активісти і частина громади вважають
знищення зелених зон стало можливим через те
що землі незаконно передали з комунальної власності у приватну
І що відповідати за це має мер міста Володимир Карплюк
Сам він з цим категорично не згодний
Каже - всі його дії законні,
зелених зон залишилося багато
а все, що відбувається в місті
іще шість років тому в генплані розвитку міста
затвердили депутати ще попереднього скликання
Цей генеральний план проходив
громадські слухання
І таким чином, ми отримали…
моя команда і я отримали той генеральний план
який, згідно закону про регулювання
містобудівної діяльності
нам потрібно було виконувати
Вже два роки Генпрокуратура проводить слідчі дії щодо діяльності голови міськради Ірпеня
Час від часу порушуються
різні кримінальні провадження
Створення злочинного угруповання,
фіктивне підприємництво
незаконне виділення земель, знищення на них лісів
Деякі справи закриваються
Сам Карплюк відкидає всі звинувачення слідчих
і робить такий собі хід конем
Він заявив про намір балотуватися в Верховну Раду
і подає у відставку з посади міського голови - добровільно
Каже, що не через тиск громадськості
а щоб підтримувати Ірпінь на загальнонаціональному рівні
Більшість міськради голосує "за"
Представник опозиції вважає,
що Карплюку взагалі не місце у політиці
Але слова йому не дають
*вигуки: Ганьба!
"Все буде Ірпінь!" Так звертається до мешканців міста Володимир Карплюк
і сміливо рекламує результати своєї роботи
нові парки, сквери, фонтани, дитячі садки, школи
Деякі жителі Ірпеня відповідають меру
ось такими плакатами
Інші ж - не вважають його винним
А що ви думаєте, він один вирубує?
Це не його провина. Це зверху
Це було заплановано ще за Януковича
Якщо щось проти нього є, хай покарають
Якщо ж ні… то він багато зробив для міста.
Крім нього ніхто так не робив
Громадські активісти Ірпеня не радіють відставці одіозного посадовця
і переймаються, що з депутатською недоторканністю
він уникне відповідальності за знищення лісів
Утім відставка мера не означає,
що лісові скандали в Ірпені припиняться
Нині міськрада вносить вже свої зміни
в генеральний план розвитку міста
Активісти сумніваються,
що ці покращення будуть на користь містян
а не забудовників